tomorrow will mark the end of an era for
Richard Simmons his iconic fitness
studio slim ends will close down after
42 years now we spend a lot of time
there with Richard and now he is only
sharing with us what it means to me now
that was a 33 year old Richard his
studio had been open about six years
they trust me with their lives and I
trust them with my life today as patrons
entered some of the final classes
Richard tells ET and an exclusive
statement quote in 1974 I opened slim
ins as a way to help people make
positive changes in their lives by
having fun while exercising thank you
for always supporting and loving me I
will take the time for myself to be the
best I can be and so should you
I love you always keep sweating but the
truth that matters you have no idea what
you do to people he was emotional the
last time we spoke to him on camera
recently he's been absent from the
public eye and during our last phone
interview in March
Richard denied rumors he is ill and
hiding or being held captive by his
housekeeper instead he said he just
needed some private time for all the
people that are worried about me please
don't be